what kind of person does she look like
she's a doctor right
this is a medical example and I'm going
to give you some statistics and
probabilities that are exactly as a
doctor would receive it and as the
doctor would also give to you so I'm
just going to put everything in the
context of that kind of warning all
right
so let me give you a scenario let's
suppose that your doctor has said to you
hey I think you are at risk of this very
particular disease is quiet rare it's
quite rarely affects 0.1% of the
population but there's variety of things
in your you know symptoms what I think
you might have this let's put you in for
a test okay and she says this test is
95% accurate would you rate that is like
good accuracy that's pretty good yeah I
would say right so she says this is the
test this is the rate at which it
affects the particular disease affects
the population and then you get your
test results back good morning quickly
come here take a seat grab the door
thank you it needs to be shut properly
cheers alright so you do the tests you
make your review appointment and she
sits you down it says hey look I've got
bad news you test positive right now
just be careful write positive so it's
like a good thing hooray but of course
in the context of a disease test what is
positive me we think you have it we
think you've got it right you test
positive on this test
what's the chance what's the probability
that you actually have the disease
because we agreed like we think this is
pretty accurate right but it's not a
hundred percent it's not a hundred cent
now this is in the field of what we're
looking at at the moment just before
you're asking question okay you might
want to ask for some clarified question
like what does this mean what is that
mean I'm deliberately leaving this just
as vague as the doctor might hear it and
might say it to you
so I'm if you want to clarify some
things we'll get to that choice later
but I'm not going to I'm not going to
drop you right the deep end and expect
you to like do a calculation on your own
good morning take a seat quickly please
I'll give you some options I can't give
you some options let's do this multiple
choice style okay now in a second I'm
gonna ask you to vote on this and I'm
not this is you know this is not a test
doesn't matter right but I want to see
what your intuition is okay here's the
way I'm going to do the test in about 30
seconds I'm gonna ask you to close your
eyes and you're going to put up one or
two or three or four fingers
corresponding to and today it's a beer
to see it's a D do you think there's a
100 chance you have the disease do you
think there's a 95% chance you have the
disease and so on and so on so these are
the options I'll just review for those
of you who are just walking in this is a
particular disease it's fairly rare the
test is this accurate okay which do you
think one two three or four is the
chance you have the disease so I've just
been talking all this time to stall for
you and give you a bit of thinking time
your thinking time is over now close
your eyes because I want you to vote for
this without the influence of like oh
she's really smart I think I'm just
gonna agree with her okay so everyone
close your eyes I'm waiting for everyone
okay and if you just walked in you just
look at this okay yes it's all right
it's bare basic situation
okay okay all eyes closed so almost
there we're almost there okay and I'd
like you to good morning I'd like you to
hold up one finger if you think the
answer is eight a hundred percent two
figures if you think the answer is B 95
percent three fingers if you think the
answer is C nine point five percent and
four fingers if you think the answer is
D which is two percent so I'm looking
for one two three or four fingers I'm
gonna wait till everyone votes and hold
up nice and high I just want to see like
I want to see clearly okay there's a
couple of people who haven't voted just
yet come and take a seat quickly please
okay one two three
keep your eyes shut I really want you to
make sure the options again just to
remind you one finger for a hundred
percent two fingers for ninety five
percent three fingers for 9.5% and then
four fingers for two percent okay so
give the opportunity to change your mind
you're happy all right now keep your
hands up in the air with those hands
there and now I want you to open your
eyes and have a look around you okay
keep your hands up straight so that
other people can see what your vote was
okay so clearly it looks to me like
option three seems to be dominating is
the sense of getting we have a few
people in option B got some crazy but
yeah okay
alright are you ready to hear what the
answer is e none of the above
okay you ready for the answer you ready
the answer is d two percent now some of
you are like oh yes it pays to be the
hipster and take the dog mainstream
option okay and others of you are like
how can that possibly be that doesn't
look like it makes any sense whatsoever
a fun fact right when we are designing
multiple choice questions for you right
we designed these things called
distractors that's literally what they
call it a distractor is an answer which
seems plausible or might flow out of a
common mistake but but it is close
enough for you to think I think it might
be this one which I successfully did for
all of you right this looked like a
pretty good option right it was a very
successful distractor for all of you but
of course you're wondering how actually
can we argue that this might be true let
me try and show you let's get back to
the original statement this particular
disease affects 0.1% of the population
part of why this is tricky by the way if
you just walk to you please get your
books out you're here for maths right
part of the reason why this is tricky is
because actually our brains are not well
geared to think statistically in terms
of percentages right so what I'm gonna
try and do is put this you know
illustrate this in terms that might make
this a little more sensible to you 0.1%
of population let's suppose we had a
thousand people a fabulous take half the
school okay if you had a thousand people
according to this statistic how many of
those people would you expect of course
not a guarantee it's just probabilities
but how many people would you expect in
that 1000 to have good morning the
disease how many thing about it one
percent would be one in a hundred
wouldn't it that's a fact literally what
one percent means one hundred so 0.1
percent is not one in a hundred it's one
in a thousand so in our 1000 people in
our 1000 people this is a thousand
people by the way
in this 1,000 people you'd expect
statistically probably there should be
exactly one person who has the disease
let's call this unfortunate guy sorry
okay so one in a thousand here are the
stats right this is what we expect now
let's come back to the other idea the
test is 95% accurate what does that mean
for a test to be 95% accurate for these
people now if you're kind of wondering
you're like I think this question was
unfair because like I was totally
tricked by that 9.5 percent on the 95
percent Rama you're actually partly
correct because 95% accurate can
actually mean a whole bunch of different
things okay and it's kind of tricky to
know what it means but often we don't
get told because it's quite complicated
right here's one simple example of what
it could mean a test is 95% accurate
okay so if we had you know a hundred
people who have the disease they
actually we know for sure like we've
tested we can be very confident they've
got the disease of those 90 those 100
people right five of them are going to
be told you're healthy even though they
have the disease does that make sense
like for five percent of them they're
wrong we give them what we call a false
negative we tell them they're healthy
even though they're sick okay
but also it goes the other way doesn't
it right you've got these 999 healthy
people and some of them are going to be
told they have the disease right you
were hoping you're in this situation
right it's like I hope I'm healthy and
the test is positive which is a mistake
right so let me ask you this right of
these 1000 people 5% of them despite
being healthy are going to be told they
have the disease how many people is that
thank you sir what's 5% no no no you
don't need calculus think think these
are easy numbers right five percent is
five and a hundred yeah focus it so in a
thousand it should be 50 right there's
50 people okay so now we know who's
likely to have the disease and we also
know who's likely to test positive for
the DS which are two separate things you
test positive that's what happened to
you so in this diagram where are you you
test positive we know this to be a fact
you are
Hanan you test positive right most of
these people are healthy but inside this
red box despite being healthy some have
been told they have the disease right
they're toasted positive so in other
words the people who test positive are
inside the box does that make sense
right what's the chance that you had
this person when you know you're in the
red box well there's one chance we have
the disease out of a sample space of 51
in 50 what percentage is that 2% do you
see how counterintuitive probability in
statistics can be and this is not a
manufactured situation this is what
people all around the world are told
every single day by their doctors and
then they have to make an expectation by
the way when I showed you those answers
before right
these same these same responses or same
options were given to doctors right to
try and say if you were sitting with a
patient what would you actually tell
them like what's your chance of having
the disease and I don't want to scare
you but the doctors had a pretty similar
representation of answers to this
question than you did right which should
be shocking in one sense you're like oh
my goodness one of my doctors telling me
but it also should make a lot of sense
because people who go into medicine are
generally know people who have
mathematics theories or things like that
right this is counter intuitive that's
why it's so important we think about
today's topic which I'd love you to make
a heading is conditional probability